whoa we just witnessed two massive Quirk
Evolutions within a single chapter the
so-called Quirk doomsday is here and
that's on top of the fact that one of
the main characters in the story is
actively dying right now like what is
going on horikoshi this is just insane
so let's get into it you guys know how
this works if you enjoy my mha videos
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now to
help me out with that YouTube algorithm
and I know that over 50 of you guys who
are watching this video right now are
not subscribed do me a big favor and
subscribe right now and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications we are trying to hit 2
million subscribers here on the channel
and every subscription matters if you
still haven't seen my favorite video
that I've made here on the channel about
how Deku could have become a villain in
mha check it out Link in the description
and in the pinned comment finally this
video will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned after an emotional and
violent showdown between ochako and toga
toga managed to get up close to ochako
and stab her in the abdomen we saw this
in the previous chapter and this was
clearly a serious injury a potentially
fatal injury and the entire fandom
suddenly began speculating about whether
ochako could really die in this art
personally even though ochako's
potential death would be an absolutely
massive twist that would shake the
entire world of mha to its core and that
would likely turn Deco into a completely
different and darker character I just
don't think that horikoshi will go
through with killing her but let's just
see what happens to his credit horikoshi
has had the courage to kill off some
decently important characters in the
past but I just don't think that ochako
would be killed off she seems too
popular and too important at the very
end of the previous chapter we saw
flashback in which twice asked toga why
she still hadn't picked out a villain
name and why she's just using her real
name instead the latest chapter picks up
during that same flashback and we see
that basically the entire league of
villains was part of the villain name
discussion that took place sometime in
the past Mr compress points out that
toga and shigaraki are the only ones who
haven't chosen a special villain name
and while this is technically true
shigaraki is still using a fake name his
real name is of course tenko shimura but
it goes by tomura shigaraki that said it
is true that he doesn't have a cool
sounding villain name like Decay daddy
so point taken the villain suggests some
pretty cringe villain names for toga but
toga and Dobby both shut them down as
being lame shigaraki then talks about
the past in which there was no clear
distinction between heroes and villains
back when quirks first appeared in the
world it was chaos and you couldn't tell
who was trying to help you and who was
trying to hurt you it was a complete
mess so you didn't yet have heroes and
villains in the conventional sense then
eventually as heroes and villains
emerged in a more clear-cut way and both
heroes and villains began adopting code
names still shigaraki says that he
doesn't need such things and toga agrees
she joined the league of villains in
order to finally be herself she joined
so that she could finally live her life
as himikotoga after all the hardships
she faced because of who she was and so
adopting a different villain name now
doesn't make sense for her back on the
battlefield in the present time toga
screams at ochakult not to pity her at
the same time as she is saying this toga
pulls out that knife out of ochako's
body and there is definitely a lot of
blood pouring out of the wound this was
not just like a scratch or a grazing
injury this was a serious injury and we
have to keep this in mind going forward
orchako replies that she is not trying
to pity toga but toga doesn't care what
pretty words ochako decides to use
ocheko just wants to talk toga out of
killing the Heroes and as soon as she is
no longer a threat toga will be locked
up and maybe even executed in fact if
she can't take her in alive orchako
might just kill toga right here now just
like Hawks did to twice toga says that
win or lose this is a battle for
survival and it's due or die toga's
Quirk then seems to evolve even further
or rather she seems to evolve the way
that she is using twice as Quirk because
she upgrades her Sad Man's parade to Sad
Man's parade 2.0 in other words togon
locks Sad Man's Legion and suddenly it's
not just twice clones that are swarming
the battlefield swarms of tsuyu's
ochakos pixie bobs and other hero clones
joined the twice clones to create a true
weapon of mass destruction the reporter
inside the helicopter who is looking
down on the battlefield calls this
nothing less than the Quirk doomsday
Theory coming to reality this grotesque
display of overwhelming power is the
face of Quirk Singularity the Clones
seem to be moving in these like massive
clumps or piles that almost look like
the tendrils of a sea monster or
something and toga commands the Clones
to crush ochako parochuk was able to
stand her ground at least for now by
using the martial arts techniques she
learned from gun head to make all the
Clones float she didn't actually hurt
the Clones but she has restricted their
movements by forcing them to float in
zero gravity now if you're wondering how
ochako is able to use martial arts
techniques after suffering a severe stab
wound to the abdomen don't worry I'm
wondering the same thing but let's move
on ocheko says that zero gravity was not
meant for hurting people and this is
what sets ochako and toga apart now
ochako can't pretend that her and toga
are the same because toga has clearly
killed people intentionally and yet
ochiko believes that deep down toga is
not a bad person a bunch of bad things
happened to her and this led her down
the path that she has been going up to
this point but back when ochakosa toga
smiling so genuinely in the middle of a
fight ocheko actually envied toga ochako
has been lucky enough to see many
genuinely happy faces in her life and
she knows that toga's smile is real and
genuine in that moment when she smiled
toga was truly happy orchako tells toga
that she should never try to hide her
feelings or her smile and as she says
this ochako is thinking of Deku now
don't cancel me on Twitter shippers but
this might be a little bit of a clue
that ochako has been hiding her full
feelings for Deku you know maybe ochako
cries out to toga telling her that she
has a lovely smile and that she won't
pretend that she didn't see her smile
this brings a torrent of tears to toga's
eyes because in the past this genuine
smile of hers is what caused people to
insult her her including her own parents
her smile is why people called her a
deviant and they told her never to smile
that way and then during this emotional
exchange we witness another Quirk
Awakening suddenly ochako is able to
make everyone around her float without
actually touching them signaling that
her Quirk has awakened and that it just
became a long range Quirk the chapter
ends as ochako says that she can't
pretend that ochako didn't commit crimes
and she doesn't intend to validate her
crimes in any way but she says that even
in spite of her crimes ochiko still
wants to be her friend she wants to talk
to her about romance and relationships
and Deku just like toga always said she
wanted in fact if toga needs blood
ocheko vows to give toga her blood for
the rest of her life as long as toga
won't need to hurt other people and that
is how this emotional chapter ends
honestly this chapter was wild we got
all of that emotional drama between toga
and ochako but at the same time we saw
both of their quirks evolve in a very
significant way these new abilities they
obtained are potential game changers
especially if Torah can figure out a way
to have every clone she creates use the
Quirk of the person whose clone they are
as for ochako one of her biggest
disadvantages has always been the fact
that she has to physically touch her
Target with her fingers in order to
activate zero gravity this meant that
ochako had to get up close and personal
to her opponent in every battle which is
both difficult and dangerous because it
forces you to put yourself in riskier
situations so yeah this is a huge deal
for zero gravity and even though ochako
doesn't want to use her Quirk too
seriously injure people using zero
gravity at long range in combination
with other quirks from her allies like a
wind Quirk would be extremely effective
against large numbers of villains but
okay so does the fact that ochako was
using martial arts and that she was able
to awake in her Court during this
chapter mean that her stabbing injury
isn't actually as bad as it looks from
the location of the injury and the
amount of blood produced you would think
that ochako would need immediate medical
attention and yet for the most part she
seemed fine during this chapter so is
the injury actually less bad than it
looks or is logical living on borrowed
time is it only a matter of time before
she collapses as a result of the injury
or maybe even dies again I said this
before but I don't see horikoshi killing
off ochako I think he has been building
towards a closer relationship between
her and Deku for a long time and that's
what I expect will happen at the end
still I have to admit it would be pretty
insane if this was ochako's last hurray
before she dies in a blaze of glory
during this Arc the fandom would be
absolutely shaken Deku would be beside
himself and his rage over learning that
ochako died could trigger some sort of
crazy one for all Quirk Singularity
transfer information this could turn
Deco into a straight up Quirk monster a
dark God of quirks Now to repeat I do
think ochako will be fine but the idea
of her dying and Deku finding out is
definitely interesting to at least think
about finally that moment at the end
where ochako offers to let toga have
some of her blood could this be the
solution to toga's problems with the law
like if she naturally craves blood
obviously you can't let her attack
people but if someone just consented to
give their some of their blood once in a
while would that calm toga down and
allow her to stop being a villain I kind
of doubt it I feel like toga's issues go
a lot deeper than just drinking some
blood once in a while but that seems to
be what the ochako is aiming at bold
strategy let's see if it pays off what
do you guys think is ochiko gonna be
fine or is her injury going to catch up
to her is ochako's fate going to affect
Deku in his final battle against
shigaraki is toga going to accept Ocho
offer or is she gonna keep being a
villain until someone stops her by force
don't forget to leave your feedback down
in the comments once again reminding you
to check out my video about how Deku
could have become a villain in mha it's
my favorite video I've ever made here on
the channel Link in the description and
in the pinned comment if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
amateur content in the future drop a
quick like right now to help me out with
the YouTube algorithm and don't forget
that we are shooting for 2 million
subscribers so every subscription
matters it's completely free to
subscribe on YouTube so it would mean a
lot to me if you would as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya Space Cowboys